all right so it's uh it's four o'clock
and again you know thanks for taking the
time out of your day today it's
already the end of september pretty much
september 23rd next week is already uh
october and the year has gone by
very quickly and you know we've come out
with a lot of new tools this year at
order flows and our latest tool is the
order flows flow bounce and
really what the way i describe it is
combining order flow with aspects of
volume profile rather than simply
relying on the order flow itself you
know you're adding in aspects of
analysis from the volume profile you
know i always say
order flow is a tool right it tells you
what's happening in the market
and you know when you start
using order flow with other forms of
analysis you know it really
opens wider
you know sort of your your net for
fishing so to speak in the market
and you know that's sort of the way that
we're going in the future with uh order
flows is you know we're i want to show
you how to use it with other parts of
market analysis so you know before we
begin you know just a brief disclaimer
you know we're all adults here right we
do understand that trading involves risk
and risk capital is money that can be
lost without jeopardizing your your life
or your lifestyle right and you know if
you're going to trade trade with money
you know that you put aside specifically
for trading you know you don't want to
trade your mortgage money you know
sometimes people have this concept of
um
you know a race against time oh mike you
know i need to learn how to trade in the
next 30 days because i just lost my job
and
you know i've only got enough money to
last me about 30
you know one month two months and that's
why i need to start trading you know
don't don't put yourself in that
position um you know if
you are in that position you probably
shouldn't be trading in all honesty so
today's agenda what we'll be covering is
what is the flow bounce i'll be talking
about settings markets time frames and
time frame settings you know
it's
when you're dealing with a an indicator
of any
sort right it shouldn't be specific to
just one market
right because you know if you have a
method of trading that only works in uh
you know mini nasdaq
but doesn't work in any other markets
well
it's probably not going to work
consistently for a long time you know it
may work
now you know may work on on the last two
months of data that you analyze then
going forward it may
you know work off and on for the next
uh you know two weeks and then you know
after that just completely falls apart
you know a solid method of trading
should be transferable to other markets
and preferably other time frames
and that's why i get into a bit you know
with with the examples and everything
we talked about the differences of the
settings of the flow bounce talking
about the trade entry signal and at the
end again i said i'll be taking
questions
at the end of the presentation so you
know again if you have a question or
anything uh feel free to put it in the
chat or the question box again but i
won't be getting to them until the end
of
the session
so
you know just really briefly you know
some of the misconceptions about what
order flow can do is you know a lot of
times people think that order flow is
going to give them every single turning
point in the market like
you know sometimes you see the market
drop sharply and then rally up you know
people think that order flow is going to
give them exactly that turning point you
know and it's going to tell them exactly
what happened well it doesn't okay it
doesn't find every single turning point
in the market right there's a lot of
randomness in the market and what do i
mean by randomness is you know there's a
lot of orders coming in for many
different reasons
okay but order flow allows you to see
when market activity is not random
right when everybody is sort of piling
in to the market or everybody's running
into the exit or
traders get trapped at a certain price
location or
you know there's support forming or
there's resistance forming or momentum
is starting to pick up right it order
flows uh order flow allows you to parse
out those
moments in time
when it's crystal clear okay it's not
going to give you every single turning
point in the market right it just
doesn't
and again like it should be able you
should
order flow
can be used on different time frames
okay and you know i'll be showing you
charts later
you know
sub one minute charts people think oh my
gosh sub one minute charts i can't trade
that that's too fast then they go look
at a three range chart and or a 133 tick
chart but you know 30 second chart is
fine i use 30 second charts
uh i even know traders that use five
second charts 15 second charts but
you know
then i see people trading with heat maps
and and looking at a dome and they're
just really trading almost every single
tick that goes through but you know if i
sell you know look at a 30 second chart
oh my gosh you know that's so so quick
but then they're looking at a
nanosecond chart or you know they're
looking at a dome which is much faster
but with order flow okay it really
behooves you to be looking at and
trading
shorter term charts now
that doesn't mean that you get into a
position you know on a 30-second chart
you have to hold it for a minute or two
minutes now you can hold it as long as
the order flow is conducive to your
position you can hold it the rest of the
day if you want
but
the thing to remember is you know as
soon as the order flow starts changing
you should be able to pick that up
right away okay
and
you know sort of a a question that i get
you know quite often is
how is this different right how is
flow's balance difference anytime i
release a new tool everyone the question
asks
is you know how is it different from
something that else that i've released
you know the flow shifts scalper driver
delta scalper etc well
there's so many different parts of order
flow right so many different nuances so
many different ways to look at order
flow
that
you know it because there's so many
useful pieces there's delta there's
point of control
there's imbalances you know there's max
delta there's min delta there's a bid
bid volume there's ask volume cumulative
delta um you know so there's so many
different ways to
break the market down and and look at it
that
you know if you're just
looking at something like um you know
your standard indicator i don't know you
know macd or rsi yeah you're just
changing the number in the moving
average right that's that's all uh
basically that's all
many of these price based
indicators are are just basically
basically mathematical um
i'll say formulas but
sequences okay
and flow's bounce is different from
anything else that i've released before
because this is the first one that also
uses not just order flow but it uses
parts of the profile analysis
right the volume profile because you
know volume profile
is tells you how the market trading over
time right order flow tells you what's
trading right now
so you know you're able to combine
these different
ways of looking at the market is going
to give you a new view on the market
right order flow
prints what's traded okay it's the truth
okay for example five contracts trade at
a price right the trades at you know
five lots of crude trade at 71.91 that's
it there's no debating it it happened
okay but a volume profile
during the day
is constantly changing
right because you know there's volume
being printed over time at a certain
price then it moves away moves down
moves up it's evolving as the trading
day happens and
you know this is for example this is
crude oil today okay
now obviously you know it's up here at
25 and you have this
profile that's
you know you you're forming
some value up here okay well you know
there's value down here now
what are you going to do as a trader
right you know people like to look at
volume profile
they in my opinion
you know they look at a certain way
because
that's how they were that's how they
read about it in a book
right and i think oh my gosh you know i
got to start trading it this way
but
there's you could really dissect the
profile
and
break it down into smaller time periods
right and analyze the market from
that sense now you know because you know
honestly
anything that happened down here
you know at the bottom half of the
profile
right now
isn't very useful to you because you
know you're trading well above that area
that traded
you know much lower you know up below
7200 when you're trading 7225
you know what you should be focused on
is how value is is forming up here right
around where we're trading what's going
on with the value and the volume profile
you know wheat right this is wheat today
perfect example double distribution day
right your low is this red line down
here
early in the day overnight you had
you know you're coming into the day
session it looks like we're going to be
forming you know just a normal day all
right we're going to fill it out but lo
and behold you know we we went up and we
formed a higher
value area up here
right so
you know even though you got this nice
big point of control down here for most
of the day
you're above it the whole day so you
know this point of control is
not going to be useful for you in your
analysis right you want to be focusing
on what's the point of control doing
how is it forming you know now you know
i mean with honestly though with grains
it's almost like you have two sessions
right you have the night session
you know then it sort of shuts down for
a little while
and then then it reopens the day session
and you trade much more volume then then
you trade overnight
but you know there's there's still
value to be had in here if we're trading
around here but you know in this case
you know today we open up we're putting
in that higher value and it's just like
ignores the rest of it right but
there's there's pieces of information
in this value that was forming up here
right but if you're looking at sort of
the big picture
right
this information isn't going to be very
useful to you right everyone you know
you read the books on on
volume profile market profile rather
and you know they say well you know it's
going to kind of come down here you know
this is just going to be your support
well what good is that support if you're
never going to touch it you know on the
session that we're in so
you know that that just sort of leads me
to
telling you you know
don't work based off what's happened in
the past right you got to really base
your trading on what's happening now
right because you know what happened in
the past is not always indicative of the
future right i mean you know you see the
disclaimer past performance is not
necessarily indicative of the future
right and how the market traded in the
past isn't always
an example of how it's going to trade in
the future right you could look at
charts you know i've seen this pattern
100 times right and 100 times it does
this then okay you know the next time
you see it
well it's done it a hundred times so
that's the one time you you put your
trade on it doesn't work well exactly
that's what they mean because that's
where you're going to run into problems
so
remember right something that gets lost
on a lot of people is
who are you trading against right well
you're training against the more
experienced traders right the guys on
wall street right on jackson street in
chicago
they're the all-stars right they're the
first ballot hall of famers so to speak
right you think you're going to beat
them no you know you want to join them
so you want to be going
really with
how they're trading right you know they
have much deeper pockets than all of us
they can withstand a bigger deeper draw
down than us so you know if you're going
to be trying and going against them
um you know based off of sort of
traditional forms of analysis
chances are you're going to lose
okay and that's why you know in this day
and age with computers computing power
um you know on a desktop you know it's
amazing what you can do
and and the types of analysis that can
be performed because
you know at the end of the day
yeah i hate to say it but it's almost
like an arms race in terms of computing
power
and
you know most retail traders are going
to lose
so
you know the best way to do it is to
sort of
i hate to say follow along right because
in the sense you're not following along
with the crowd you're you're following
along with
the the smart money so to speak right
the professional traders so you know
just keep that in mind okay because you
know that's where order flow shines is
being able to identify
really what the the big traders the
professional traders are doing right if
you're looking at a normal bar chart you
can't determine
what uh
the volume is
right
you just can't see what volume is
trading at price
right that's why people started looking
more at a dome you know in the early
days they would look at time and sales
and they started moving to the dome
and then
you know they realized it's moving too
fast they needed another way to
categorize the data and you know the
footprint chart was born and it's a
terrific tool for looking at the data
now
markets to trade with the flows balance
well you can pretty much trade most
markets okay i don't say you can trade
every market because you know maybe
um
you know someone's gonna say well you
know i i trade cosby index well i
haven't looked at cosby index it should
trade the same way
um but you know for most of us
99.9 of us you know it's the main
markets right
es and q crude oil uh russell mini dao
buns bob uh dax uh i don't even have
gold on here or
you know euro currency even um you know
the main markets the markets that we
that we all trade now where it gets
interesting is
in the time frames to trade you know i i
find sort of the sweet spot for order
flow in general
is between 30 seconds and five minutes
charts right 30 second chart to a five
minute chart you know it could be a
one minute chart it could be a 90 second
chart maybe a two minute three minute um
you know but five minutes is about as
long as i'll go now i do keep up like a
15 minute chart um just sort of have you
know
nothing's really going on in in the
market
or you know i'm bored with the way you
know the way the market's moving you
know i i'll look at a 15-minute chart
maybe i could see something bigger in
the structure or something but really
for trading overflow you know you want
to keep it
you know less than five minutes because
again you know you really want to be
trading
what's happening now right and if you're
trading a 15-minute chart with order
flow well
for one
you're going to put in a lot of data
in the footprint in 15 minutes
and you're going to
overlook some things because it's going
to get filled in with volume
all right and and the same thing with
five minute charts that's why i say five
minutes is sort of on the extreme side
you know sort of pushing it in terms of
um
activity right you really want to take
advantage of what you're seeing right
now in the order flow as quickly as
possible right you don't want to be
putting it off putting it off and then
the move happens and you missed it
because you know you're trading such a
long time frame
now
volume based charts
are also good you know because
you know it's based on volume okay now
you have to know your markets okay
because
you're not going to trade say you know a
e-mini chart the same way you trade a
500 volume wheat chart okay because
they're two different beasts you know
500 volumes in the e-minis
could be three or four trades whereas
500 volume in the wheat chart
could take five minutes to do okay and
the same thing sort of with tick-based
charts you know they're formed
differently they're based off of each
trade that occurs whether it's you know
a one lot or a five lot or a 50 lot you
know that that's one tick so again know
your markets and you know sort of
understand
what's
uh you know what's normal
right and and what's
fast and what's slow now
so let's just sort of jump into the
settings now
i'm going to pull up some charts here
but
the purest setting you know we call it
the pure setting there's
i'm going to show you this but just
really quick you know before i jump into
the charts
on the settings there's things like a
swing filter and a swing period these
two are linked together
there's an enhanced look back filter
okay which i'll show you on the charts
so you understand it now the bounce
strength this is the important one right
it's a value between one and five okay
five being the strongest
one being the weakest okay now when i
say pure setting
the way i used to always look at this is
basically with the setting of five right
and until
we can we're able to
put it into a to a program
you know a software program i never
really looked at you know one these
lower levels right because i would look
for that the most obvious which was you
know basically the strongest but then
you know as we're able to program it i
said well you know what if i'm looking
at you know sort of
um
because you know again every market is
trades slightly different even though
generally the same
but you know what if i instead of having
such you know a high tolerance level
what if it's a little bit
um
weaker and or you know a weaker and
that's why we have a strength level of
one to five but five being the level
that
when i'm looking at a chart visually you
know i could see it
you know with the profile with the order
flow that's the normal setting okay now
there's a minimum difference level
okay which is it's like a filter
basically
um
and it deals a bit with uh when you're
looking at
the value in the profile right how far
away you are from it zero would be
disabled and again it's a value between
basically one and five with five being
the highest but if i use it i generally
use um one zero or one okay and on more
volatile markets i i may use you know a
level of
two three or four but you know those
markets would be like
nasdaq or mnq
um even ym
but
first starting point right for all
markets you know i would suggest
five again swing filter disabled if you
don't have have this checked you have
swing filter set at one
it doesn't matter what you have it set
at as long as this is not checked here
but five
and zero
that is what i call the pure setting
which is you know basically the the
setting that
when i was looking at a chart
that that's what i would use so for
example here
um
i'll just again it works on a footprint
chart as well as
a bar chart but
for today
i'm going to focus more on a
bar chart
because it's just easier to see in my
opinion i could cover it a lot quicker
because one not a lot of people you know
not everybody is
using
um a footprint chart
and
two you know there's only so much
space that you can you could have on a
on a footprint chart on a screen
um
so you know we'll start here with
this footprint chart so this is the
e-minis today okay
now the settings right which i just
talked
about okay
i have it at its lowest strength level
here one right i have swing filter
turned off
enhanced look back turned off bounce
strength one minimum difference level is
one okay
so that's about as low as you can go
disabled minimum difference and disabled
enhanced look back disabled the swing
filter and the bounce strength set at
one right you can't set it at zero right
because you're gonna set it at zero
might as well just not use the indicator
okay so
you can see here right the signals now
if i'm
looking if i set it at
here you see five
right whereas before on the other chart
this was one
okay so now bounce strength is five
okay so here you see a sell a buy a cell
up here
now when it's set at one
right you have the sell here buy buy buy
buy sell sell sell
okay so you're seeing more signals with
the weaker setting right because
in this case the bounce strength is set
at
one right which is as
low as you can go right and it's not
using the swing filter it's not using
the enhanced look back it's not using
the minimum difference level now when we
set it at
sort of the pure level which i call the
pure level of five with again no minimum
difference
no enhanced look back no swing period
you see in the cell just the cell
the by the cell
okay
and
again when i when i talk about the
pure setting again you know
this is the starting point right where
you want to really start with all
markets you know sometimes yeah i should
update the user manual because in the
user mail i don't have this part about
the pure setting i just jump right into
the settings of particular markets
and
if you
you know are using you know a low
setting like this oh my gosh you know
there's so many signals how am i
supposed to trade this is too much well
you know ideally you know really what
you want to be starting at is
you know the
the pure settings right to catch the the
move down and again you know it
it
the thing to remember right i mean
while we would like every single trade
to be a winner right you're still
reliant on the order flow right you're
still reliant on
order flow going in the direction that
you want it to right so you want to you
know for example
if you're getting short
in here
and there's no follow through order flow
well
the market's not going to go in your
direction just as
it started to go here then it just went
sideways there wasn't that order flow to
push the market lower or here right now
you're getting some here you're getting
some here this one nothing but then it
flipped and returned bullish right
here just sort of went sideways sold off
a little bit round back up then you got
a nice run up you know so again you got
to understand you understand how to
trade right it's not about
being right 100 of the time or being
right 90 of the time it's about being
right
enough of the time but
when you're having the winners
you know
here to here
being bigger than your loser right in
here right or in here right here's
doesn't look like much but this is you
know what a move from what is that 24
and a half
you know up to 30 that's a five point
move you know this is over 10 point move
you got a nice little sell-off here nice
little rally here again these don't look
like much because today
or this week the market's been going all
over the place but you know there's a
move here from
you know the 50s
you know down to what
you know 43 it's a 10-point move here
okay and and you can see a lot of these
right
you know going back
you know yesterday right fed day
you know look at that nail's this
high right here
right you have a sell-off here little
areas where you're just sort of going
back and forth um
this one about a half hour after the fed
announcement a little move there
you know trading a fed day is always
going to be tricky because um
things can turn on a dime you know but
earlier there's a nice move here right
90s 495 all the way down to 84.85
you know a little move here
but again you know because you know
people always say well you know
they see this and say oh this was a
loser well yeah you should have been
short from
up here
okay to down there um
you know but there's there's just you
know a lot of these trade this is the
overnight session right
again you know it gave you a buy signal
here it didn't really work right but
then it gave you the nice cell signal to
cover it back
i didn't go back you know previous day
this is uh the 21st
you know a little bit more difficult day
that was monday right that's the ever
grand news hitting the market you know
early in the day
some nice moves here
nice move back up here
you know again
you have a little move here
okay but then you catch the nice move
here from 40
you know up here is 55 i mean this is 10
points right here 50
but i'm not saying you would have bought
here and sold up here but you know there
was there's points to be had in the
markets okay
and
again
if you're looking at
a footprint chart
okay
and a volume profile chart
honestly it's it's hard to see right
because you're trying to juggle what's
happening
in the footprint
along with
what's happening
in the order flow okay do i got it set
up right to do so i'll make sure
um
let's go back to
you know some of these signals here so
you know here's a cell signal okay right
in here right it's actually this bar but
i'm gonna talk about this trade entry
signal a little bit later
and
you know it's moved a little bit you
know this was a massive move you know it
went down to from here here but again if
you're looking at
you know a lot of people have a profile
up on their their chart
but again
you're up here
right
there's you know point of control is you
know down here at 39 you're way off of
it and you know even earlier
you know you have volume you know all
the way down here right this volume
you know even though it prints right
earlier you know you had volume coming
in here at 28 29
um 4429
you know you want to be using
what's happening now especially with the
profile right because
it's nice that you have you know you
know your point of control is here you
know your value area is probably
somewhere up here value or low some
probably down here
but
oh how how can you use that right when
you're trading so far away from
everything right because again that's
what everyone
tells you about oh you know you got to
use uh the value area high the value
area low for the day well
what use is it going to be
right if you're trading so far away from
it right or up here at the high of the
day right this is the high of the day
at this time you know it trades 500
contracts 522.
so looking at the profile for the day
yeah honestly you you're up here at the
high what use is all this information
down there there's got to be a way to
use it and that's what we've
put into
the flows bounce right we're taking
what's you know how
the profile is forming
up here
now right
and putting it into context with what's
happening in the order flow right now
because again you know what you know
again you know having a
point of control at 33 when you're
trading 50 or 39 when you're trading 54
isn't going to be very useful to you
until you start coming back down towards
39 right
so you know that that was really the
whole goal of the flows bounces to take
the information that we're seeing
in the order flow with information from
the profile
more recent information from the profile
and put it into
a useful
tool okay so that we can use profile we
can use order flow together all right
now
let's go back here okay so
this is crude oil okay so this is a 30
second chart and see what the settings
are on this
um
okay so this is a low setting right one
and one right bound strength one minimum
difference level one okay now
is there a lot of signals well yeah
because the setting is set low it's set
at one and one
okay so this one has a minimum
difference of of one
but again balance strength is set to one
which is as low as it can be
now this one
hey what does that set at
set to two well this one has a look back
period of one but you know for example
let's just um
turn it off here
and you know we'll just set it at
five
and zero right you're gonna see a lot
less
signals
coming in right so this is the pure
setting five and zero
right again this is the setting when i
would look at a footprint i would watch
the profile
and put the two together okay
so
yeah here's the
profile or sorry here's the flows bounce
right sell buy
sell buy
buy sell sell a cell now again earlier
in the day you know people say well
you're covering up the the losing trades
yeah there was a small move here you
know it doesn't look like much but again
it's a move from about 40
down to below 20.
um obviously there's a move here up from
you know the 0.405
up in here to almost 30.
you know this one it really
didn't work this one didn't work okay
you know you have you're going to have
trades that that don't work
just as you're going to have trades that
you know do work you know this was
yesterday
in crude you know this is the trade you
know as a trader these are the trades
you love where it just sells off maybe
pulls back a little bit then sells off
sharply right
right but again now this is
when i talk about settings
these are starting points you know i
hate to sometimes
give people settings that they think
they have to use right as a trader you
have to
develop your
refine the settings based on
your personality all right now
the market doesn't care about you
personally right it doesn't know your
personality so you have to sort of
develop your own trading personality
that you're comfortable with in the
market
okay because
you can't
make the market do what you want it to
do you have to
follow along with what the market is
doing so you when i give you settings
right these are starting points because
you know every trader is different right
i know
traders that you know they they don't
they can't
stand a
any sort of heat right of position
coming against them
all right you know oh like you know just
here they only want trades like this
where it goes
directly up up up up right oh my gosh
you know i sold it at 37 i got stopped
out at 42. you know they want to jump
out the window you know trading you know
it's a rigged game
well
this is gonna you know this is what
everyone talks about right
let your winners run keep your losses
small
is knowing
where you're going to be wrong in the
market
okay and
managing it you know from a
that's what trading is right you're
taking off
risk basically okay
now
let's take a look at sort of a different
setting right um so that was the pure
setting so
because i
had crude oil is a good example
um
the swing using the swing setting here
right so you enable the swing filter and
really what that means is you're looking
for a swing high or swing low
okay
so going back to our crude chart
um
all right so you know i have swing
disabled okay
there's no check mark in it right you
could put a check mark in there to
enable it now you could choose a swing
period one
being the lowest you can't put zero in i
mean if you're gonna put zero in you
might as well just disable it but you
can put one you know three five ten you
know people like to use fib numbers um
but you know you really
i wouldn't go over 25
but
if you have a a period you know like
okay
let's
take a look okay you're gonna get less
um
less signals right because 10
is a filter
well the swing filter
but you're you're cutting out a lot of
trades okay
now does does it mean you're going to
have better trades well
that's debatable um you'll have less
trades technically you should have more
trades that are
coming in at swing highs or swing lows
you know again it's
we all love to buy lows and sell highs
right not just buy low and sell high but
if you could buy a low and sell a high
that's you you feel great right i mean
you'd love to
sell something like this right
at the high right that's what you want
and if you're using a swing filter
that's what
it's going to help you do right you can
find swing points now
again if you're if you're filtering out
you know something strong like 10 for a
swing period
you know you could play around with
finding your your level right because
five remember the bounce strength five
is
the highest you can go
okay so one is the weakest so if you
change it to one
right from five there should be a lot
more signals even though you have a
swing filter because now the bounce
strength
is much weaker
so
is there more well there's a few more
not
a lot lot because the filter of
you know a swing period of 10 is
going to
you know sort of remove a bunch of
trades so here yesterday
all right you can see
the cells you know the buys aren't
really working out that great on this
day on a market that's selling off until
it turns around then the buys will kick
in but you see the cells grouping in
here you know then the bias really start
kicking off now if for example if i take
off the swing filter
right it's going to be a lot of
you're going to see a lot more
signals
let me just drink some water here right
you see a lot of signals right because
that's as weak as you can have it
so
again you know depending you know if
you're somebody that's trading on a dome
and you're looking for reasons to be
buying or selling
yeah based on the order flow right if
you're just really looking for
um you know a few scalps again while it
may not look like much
but you know if you could be buying it
here at 69 and selling it at you know 75
you know someone that's just looking for
ticks you know it's a very useful tool
as well right as you know if you want
longer runs right again
you're getting those
moves as well so it really depends on
the setting
and
you know how how you want to trade it
okay so again the starting point you
know sort of the the
starting points would be five right for
balance strength five okay now again you
could use a swing filter with one
right which would be sort of the the
weakest swing filter so again if i have
for example
let's just go back here okay so i got
set to
one here balanced bounce strength
but if i set the swing filter to one
okay
to take out
you know a lot of these you know like
this short here
um
i might keep that one there but it's
going to take out some of these short
these
losing trades or you know some of these
trades that didn't really work out
because with the swing filter off is
basically giving you the signals anytime
it happens right so here you can see how
it's cleaned it up a bit
right you're not seeing those shorts in
here okay now it's it's a bit cleaner
you're seeing
more consistency in the signals right
and that's why we have that swing filter
because again
anytime you could
find a swing you know a turning point in
the market
now the swing filters
basically just looking for you know a
bar that's got a lower low or a higher
high okay there's no
i hate to burst people's bubble but
there's no big scientific thing behind
it it's looking for a lower low or a
higher high
on a swing sense okay
now
let's take a look at
this other setting in here right the
enhanced look back filter
all right
which
again it's
it's not something that
a lot of people are going to use because
it's going to really filter out a lot of
trades and i think it's
really well it's really for
more volatile markets okay
um you know if you're using a
fast-moving
nasdaq or mnq chart or you know you
trade you know dax chart and let's just
give you an example here dax i've got um
dax here okay so it's a 50 volume chart
right and it
dax you know 50 volume it moves
pretty decently so
you see there's there's two charts right
there's a chart on the top
there's a chart
underneath it okay now they both have
the enhanced swing filter on okay
this one is set to a strength of five
this one is set to a strength the lower
level is set to a
whoops set to a strength of one okay
so you can see at a strength of one
there's a few more signals than when
it's set to a strength of
five right but if
let me just make some changes here
if i don't have the enhanced lookback
filter on
on the top chart
and
i'll set it to one so it matches up the
chart on the bottom right so they're
going to be the same except
the bottom one down here has the
enhanced look back filter on
okay
okay so they're both set to a level of
one
the bottom chart has the enhanced
lookback filter the top one does not
all right so you can see
obviously there are
a lot more signals right so you know on
a market like dax you're not going to
want to honestly you're not going to
want to use a level of one
right you're going to want to use a
stronger level because it's slightly
more volatile than your normal market
all right so
if
you know let's let's play around a
little bit i'll
i'll make this
a five
bounce strength of five
the bottom one i'll keep the enhanced
lookback filter on but i'll change the
bounce strength
to five
and you can see here
right now
at five
you're getting some decent signals
even without the enhanced
um
the enhanced look back filter
you know you're getting some of the same
you know you're gonna get some of this
you're going to get the same ones
that you would have with the enhanced
signal but you're going to get the ones
that
aren't enhanced okay if that makes sense
right so you can see right in this
period here in the morning
with the enhanced
filter on there was no trades
without it
you're catching all these little
rotations up and down up and down up and
down
right back and forth
right
you're just getting these two cell
signals here
with the
enhanced feature
but without the enhanced feature you
know you're getting this nice buy here
um you're still getting those cells
again a little cell here you're getting
more trades right
but again you know people say well you
know this was a losing trade this was
losing trade you know it's it's about
cutting your losses short to catch the
ones
that are
going to
ultimately
pay off right catch the nice moves
right it's not about catching every
single move in the market yeah you know
i would
love to have a indicator that's going to
tell me to sell here buy here sell here
keep it short
cover it here get short again here cover
here short again up here
buy here add some more add some more but
you know
overflow can help you that's why we
develop different tools right because
what's happening
that's telling you to get short here
right is is a unique thing in the order
flow right but now you know on a
different way of analyzing order flow it
could be telling you to buy here as well
so there's there's so many different
ways to use order flow right
there's not just one way to use order
flow let's take a look at
gold right gold had that nice move down
late in the day
what do i have on here
okay so it's set to five right again
this is the pure settings just five
right disabled disabled five and zero
are there any trades here well there's
there's a system by here a little move
up um
excuse me
you know some on a market that's selling
off sometimes you're going to find
yourself with these buys now
again i said it's a starting point right
some days are going to be better than
others okay i mean
in the morning early european hours you
know three in the morning chicago time
you get a nice buy and i sell and i sell
it struggled the early on
in the us here here here
you know a little bit back and forth and
but that's why we have the filters right
again
if i were to change this to
um
let's talk about the minimum difference
level okay so i'll use
a minimum difference level
of i don't know you know one
well zero would be disabled one would be
at the minimum of the minimum difference
level two a little bit stronger three
four five a little incrementally
stronger now if i was using a minimum
difference level
i don't have to stay with five for the
bounce strength
right i could use
you know one
because now i've got
whoops a slightly different filter so i
could add you know i could make it a
little bit stronger on the minimum
difference level because now i got
bounce strength as low as it can be
right so it's going to give me a lot of
signals but now i want to find
you know sort of
hard to describe the difference level
but but it deals with you know on the
order flow
versus previous bars
okay
but i'll set it to two here one and two
so just to give you
you know
a feel for it's you know how
what it's going to change right so now
you're seeing
a little bit more consistent signals
here right a buy here again on this
market that was dropping you get long
you can stop that get long get stopped
don't get long get stopped out
and you can get long here
long here
um
this one in here
gave the long the stop job then got you
short this long a little bit here's a
nice little long these shorts paid out
here's another nice long over here
later in the day
you know late in the day there wasn't
much but in the overnight session
or the morning session rather
it's a nice sell-off here it's a little
sell-off here there's a sell-off here
you know not because now i've
using
sort of a different aspect of reading
the order flow
in the sense of the minimum difference
level minimum difference level is going
to measure differences in one bar versus
previous bars okay that's where the
minimum difference level is going to be
and
setting it at one would be comparing it
to the previous bar two would be
comparing it to the second bar three
we don't see we didn't see a need to go
back
more than five bars so anywhere between
one and five is is fine
um as well
uh go back to my gold chart here right
this was
was that this was yesterday right fed
day
okay again you're not going to trade
right at one o'clock um when the fed
makes their announcement but afterwards
you know there's some trades to be had
there all right
so does it move from what 86
down to we got the buy signal 68
you know these are those moves as a
trader you want to be on that side of
the market right you don't want to be
long right you know sometimes what
people do is they
they miss a move right they miss this
move here from
79 80 all the way up to you know 85
and then
you know they finally get long up in
here then they holding it starts going
against them they don't take the sell
signal then it starts to go back up and
okay yeah now here they're rubbing their
hands together thinking this is it
we're going back up and then it starts
to go back up to get the cell signal
rather than get out or get short they're
still long you know then it breaks down
like that that's
that's
where you have to develop yourself
as a trader right you have to
um
be able to cut it basically you know cut
the cut the trade and go in the
direction of the trade you know
especially on a fed day again you know
i'm not a big advocate for trading on
fed days i've traded fed days and some
days i've done really well other days
i've had my head chopped off and
shoved up
of certain body parts but um
you know yet you have to be able to
adjust right then that comes with
being a trader right you get this trade
here
right you're going up up up and then it
sort of stalls up here again you know i
could analyze the order flow i don't i'm
just using a bar chart sort of
give you a more of an overview but again
you could run it on a bar chart you
could run it on a footprint chart right
but for this presentation i'm just
showing it on a bar chart
if you start seeing you know the selling
coming in right if i was looking at a
footprint chart if i see selling
imbalances and things like that coming
in here um you know maybe some market
exhaustion
that's my sign to get out okay
just as if i'm here right getting short
okay and then it starts coming back on
me well
you know that's your sign to get out
don't wait for it to trade all the way
up here you know to get out you got to
get out as as quickly as possible to a
trade that's not working out i'm going
to talk about
where
you know you where you want to be
placing your stops you know in these
markets right you know this is these
other trades right as a trader you know
start on 8 35 you get long here 75
okay you trade it up oh you know up here
at uh
78.60 there's a sell signal okay so
you're along from 75
in here out at 78 short at 78 back down
to 75. okay
you're done
done for the day basically
um you don't have to sit through the fed
announcement and and
you know pull your brains out
now remember
every market trades slightly different
right and as a result we have found that
you know you're going to want to make
slight adjustments
in
the settings
right it doesn't mean that you're making
drastic setting changes you know if you
find
a setting that works for you in a
particular market
you're generally going to stick with it
right what do i have here
i forgot already five no i got one and
two right minimum difference level one
and two let's look at uh
nasdaq okay let me queue rather
uh what do i got here well i think i got
one a similar setting in here
but if not i'll just change it to
well i got one and four here okay
you know if i trade gold right my
settings are are one and two first thing
i'm gonna do when i look at a market
like
um
mnq or dax or a market that trades
similarly
i'll use the same settings right
one and two right that i'm using on this
gold chart that would be my my jumping
off point now it doesn't necessarily
mean that it's going to be exactly the
same
in in terms of you know
finding trades but it should be
relatively you can see it says
calculating here you know relatively
similar because you know as long as it's
a market and mnq and nq
move around quite a bit so
it's one of those things that
you know more volatile markets um you
know again you're going to want that
setting to be
the minimum difference level you could
use it to
you know to your advantage so here right
one and two okay so the bounce strength
is very is as weak as it can be right so
you're seeing a lot of signals
and
i had the
setting for the minimum difference level
set to two okay so
you know you're seeing
you're getting some nice moves here
right
300 up to you know 340.
but you're still getting you know some
of these this this sort of this chop
right we sort of came into the support
area in here you can see it right there
you can see it right here a little bit
of back and forth um yeah you can always
he'd say clean it up but
you know if you were to make it stronger
you probably have less signals you know
difference level four
because
nasdaq is about as volatile a market
movement as you can get and when i use
the term
volatile i mean it takes a market time
it's got to cover a certain amount of
price levels to find
a level that it can trade at
and everyone can be happy right nasdaq
it seems nobody's happy that's why you
get such big price distortions
up and down okay so just give it a
second here
but you know other markets like oh m and
q here this is a
setting of
five right this is the pure setting five
right nothing else
m and q right
now market drop down here okay he gets
stopped out there
he buying it off this low you know still
maybe you cover it up here look for your
next trade comes in here back up again
you know this one doesn't work out this
again nice trade these cells
don't really work out
this cell does
right again this this is this is the
setting of five right the the pure
setting right here is cache
would cache open up here
this bar
right so just after the cache open boom
kicks off
this buy signal around the 219 220 area
in here
you know
it's 100 point move right that's
this is what
15 220
right in here signal is coming in on
this bar
within 8 35
up to
what is that 905
30 minutes it's 100 point move right
there but anyway you know i'm not saying
every move is going to be like that you
know but you can catch those moves
okay
and then as a trader that that's those
are the moves you're done right you
don't have to sit around and bang your
head and
fear you're going to give money back you
know
you're done for the day turn off the
computer and go do
whatever you like to do
so going back to this
chart
so
all right so set the one and four right
and this one was set to
three enhanced look back set to three
okay
strength of three now with enhanced look
back you know you can change it doesn't
have to be three it doesn't have to you
know it's up to you to adjust the
settings right people say well yeah
you're looking at today's you know and
and it did well well what you do is you
know you would
you could use market replay to go
through all all the different settings
this was the day before fed day right
again you know i'm not a big advocate
for trading on fed day because you're
going to have moves you know just like
this but you know imagine you're getting
long somewhere in here around 60.
you know it's a 50-point move very quick
against the 30-second chart
um you know so you can see how
it performed
right again you know not it's not gonna
it's not designed to tell you to sell up
here and buy down here sell up here buy
down here right what's happening in the
overflow here
is decipherable what's happening in the
other field here is decipherable what
happened down here is decipherable what
happened down here is decipherable all
right so there's certain activities
in the order flow that
you know just
are really telling to a trader right
you know uh go back
another day you know i i wish it would
have caught this move but it didn't all
right it's not going to catch every
single move
um okay so it didn't catch this move up
but
it caught this move down
okay this was
is this the 21st so that sunday night
you know imagine you're getting short
here or even in here right
what is that 9.85
you know even if you sell it down to
here in the 70s down here is the 60s
down years 40s
but again you know that's just monday
morning quarterbacking
you know when you're trading
you know you want to take your trade ah
i got stopped out take your trade okay i
got stepped out take your trade
okay did you get stopped out it depends
where your stop is
you know earlier in the day
again you know similar boom spikes up
get short you catch that move there um
it honestly it is a weird week with this
all this ever grand stuff
um and then the fed yesterday
you know but again two in the morning
the 80 the 0080 level 15080
up into the 140s you know there's a lot
of
flexibility right depending on your
trading style right let's take a look
this is euro currency
where am i what's the setting i think
this is the
pure setting of five
we have five
okay
again you know
this is a buy here but again do you want
to be buying after the market you know
you're up here at the high of the day do
you want to be buying that probably not
you'd probably be looking you know when
you came up here for this little short
up here not the biggest move but again
you know you can short 48
and you're covering it down at 42 43
that's 10 ticks all right trades in half
ticks and halves you know there's a buy
down in here
you know there's a cell here
i wouldn't even consider this as short
because you already should have been
short from up here this one yeah you
would have gotten stopped out probably
or maybe broken even
um the day before fed day again you do
that get your short signal right up here
for this big move down
those are those trades as a trader
yeah you're going to be doing cartwheels
again a nice move up again you know so
you get stopped down in here or you take
a small loss or maybe you you know this
one would have stopped you out but you
get short in here okay nothing's
happening you get the buy signal in here
you cover it you make a tick two ticks
or maybe you scratch it then you catch
that move up right
it's not about every single trade being
a winner yeah we would like that right
you're getting long here but then you
get sell signal coming in right
afterwards you get short
you catch the move
right and the same things
in here
you know now the market's trade 24 hours
so you know
a lot of moves happen while we're asleep
you know that's that's why having a tool
such as markers is is going to help you
now again i talked about
the dax right with the
bounce strength at
five versus one right with the enhanced
strength so you saw that already how you
can um
[Music]
you know in in a different
market have
different signals you know depending on
you know what you have the strength set
up you know one
up here five down here you're going to
get less signals coming in right
now the other thing i want to talk about
is real quick is the trade entry signal
okay now it's something i developed and
i use in my trading to help me determine
to take a trade or pass on the trade it
keeps me out of bad trades right the
trades where there's no follow-through
order flow in the direction of the trade
at the end of the day whether or not you
buy is sort of inconsequential to the
market right the market's going to do
what the market's going to do so if you
buy
you also need other people you want to
be buying while they're also buying
all right i mean you could get in before
they're buying but once you buy you also
need other traders to be buying along
with you okay now it doesn't necessarily
mean they're reading order flow or
anything but you know their perception
of the market is bullish if
they're buying right just as if you're
selling you need that follow-through
order flow to come through if there's no
follow-through order flow the
probability the trade will work out is
decreased right it's going to have a
higher chance of failing
so the trade entry signal one enabled
will signal after the signal bar
when the subsequent bars exhibit the
complementary order flow in the
direction of the trade signal
so again you could use choose to use a
trade entry signal or not by unchecking
the box next to it now the zone right is
still going to draw out i'm going to
talk about the zones a little bit later
but
let's just sort of jump into it here so
the trade entry signal okay you can
enable it or disable it by checking this
box here okay now i use settings of two
and two so meaning
market has to move
two ticks in the direction
of the trade of the signal
over the next two bars and if it doesn't
there's no
trade signal okay the zone is different
than the trade signal trade signal is
going to be what you you buy or sell off
of all right
so again you know you want to be trading
in the direction of the market you don't
want to be trading against the markets
so
when enabled
right a signal will print on your chart
in the bars or bar immediately after the
signal bar not directly on the signal
bar so what this means is when the
conditions of the flow bounce are met
for a trade signal to be generated the
order flow in the next bar or bars need
to be in the direction of the trade
signal okay again you can decide how
many ticks or how many bars you want you
know some markets
slower moving markets you can adjust it
to one tick
okay
in some markets you might not even want
to use it right in some of the thicker
markets like ultrabonds
sometimes i don't use it depending on on
the tool that i'm using
okay
because i want to basically take every
trade that comes on on a market that
doesn't move around so much all right
so
it's
again you could decide on how many bars
so let's take a look here okay i'll show
you a couple slides that i'll show you
in real time so this is the trade entry
signal enabled okay so you can see
this is the signal bar
right in here
and then afterwards
you have
the
actual signal the triangle up there
right it's not on the signal bar
okay and this the settings will show you
whether it's
enabled
or disabled right having the check mark
next to it the word enable okay if it's
checked then it's enabled
and you can see in here there's zones
drawn out
that
there's no signal generated it's just
the zone drawn out from the signal bar
itself
okay but there's no signal there's no
trade that you're going to take there
just as over here right this is the zone
so you have the signal bar then it's
telling you to get short here just as
you have the bullish bar down here
right the first bullish bar as this
market was still dropping
didn't have that follow-through order
flow right and it's important because if
a market is dropping dropping dropping
dropping
you you want their energy
getting signals to buy on a falling
market
you want to buy as at the low right
because you want the market to find its
low then turn around and start going up
and that's where
if you're looking at the order flow
right and again you know it doesn't have
to have to be orderful you just use
the bar right you use the price action
the price action's got to start going up
okay
because if it doesn't
it's going to keep going lower right you
the last thing you want to do is buy get
stopped out buy get stopped out buy get
stopped out you want the market to keep
finding its level
and then start turning around that's
where you participate
okay
so
just
again really quick
if it's disabled
it's not going to give you
this okay sorry let me start over when
you disable the trade entry signal so if
you uncheck
the box right where it says enable if
you uncheck that
then
every time you have conditions met in a
bar
it will print
the
blue triangle down or sorry blue
triangle up or a by or a red triangle
down for a cell
okay now please note though as the bar
is forming
and the order flow is coming in a signal
may appear and disappear okay but
because
the bar is still forming right the bar
is not closed but once the bar is closed
and there's a signal it will not
disappear it will not repaint so on a
chart
how it looks right trade
entries
signal where it says enabled is disabled
right so every bar that has a signal
will also have the
red triangle for a cell or a blue
triangle for buy
and again you might not want to use this
on all markets
i use
i disable it when i say not use it um
one on a market like ultra bonds um
bonds you know interest rates that move
a bit slower you know because those are
markets that once they pick up ahead of
steam just keep going in that direction
i disable trade entry signal because i
want to see every single signal that
appears
and then decide for myself if i'm going
to
going to take it basically i'm using
you know the the flows balancer would
flow scalper or flow shifts as the tool
to identify it so that i
take some of the heavy lifting off my
shoulders right and then i can decide if
i want to take the trade or not but
again if i'm
using
you know if i'm automated it if i'm
using markers
from the indicator store
it keys off of the
triangle right that's what it's reading
right so if you're automating it um you
want to be careful right you want the
order flow to be going in the direction
of the bar so
for example let's pull up some charts
here
um
i don't know let's stick with gold here
okay so
for example well
let me find a better example here
okay so for example here right so i have
trade entry signal turned on and in the
middle
here there's this little blue box this
is the zone right it's telling you
conditions are met in this bar for a
potential buy all right so the market
has been coming off coming off coming
off
and it's giving you a signal that
there's a potential long in the markets
okay right in here
but there's
no follow through order flow right you
just get red bar doji bar and the market
goes lower this you know if you get long
if you bought this
it would have stopped you out you would
got stopped out period
right which is not what you want right
you want to get long
and have follow through order flow right
you want to get short like you are here
and have the follow-through order flow
right to catch the move you know you
don't want to
buy it and then immediately get stopped
out three bars later
right now if
i disable that's using the trade entry
signal if i disable it right here
trade entry signal i uncheck that box
then it doesn't matter what values are
in here for trade price level or trade
validity
it will just it will draw the signal
there tell me hey get long right here on
the signal bar okay okay i get long
and what happens it fails i get stopped
out i take the loss so this is
you know the way i'm able to filter out
and again you could take this trade
you know this one worked right this is
one trade worked one trade didn't but
you know imagine
you're staring at this gosh you know i
wish i didn't take this trade well using
the trade entry filter
keeps you out of that trade because it
doesn't have the follow-through order
flow
you understand
all right because even though it's
markets selling off and you're getting
you know based on the order flow based
on the profile
you know you're getting a signal of a
potential long
but then
there's no follow-through buying by any
other market participants instead you
got
continued selling you don't want to be
buying right there right but over here
market shot up then the selling pressure
came in you know it came into a level
you know on on volume you know based on
profile etc
and the order flow was bearish
and you want to take that trade right
because now you're getting that
follow-through order flow coming in in
this case in the next bar so it's the
trade that you want to take right
you keep kept out of this trade
but you're in on this trade
you know if you've ever gone over your
trading records right
you know maybe you're uh
50 you know whatever 50
trader right half winners half losers
imagine you could just remove
a couple percent a few trades
that you got stopped out on immediately
that's where having something like a
trade entry signal having to follow
through
order flow
to
sort of confirm the trade is going to
help you now i in the past
you know he's always laugh at you know
people that would
say well what you know um
i've got uh
you know be like here oh you know we got
a double top here right here in here but
i need confirmation i need the market to
break down um you know below the support
area
of
72 right your double tops up here at 74
and a half right here double top
but
it looks like a double top but lots of
times they don't recognize it until it
gets down here well if you're waiting
until it breaks sort of this support
area down here you're short down here at
but you really should be short up here
right this is where the order flow is
going to help you immensely right
because you can know based on the order
flow that it's it's bearish here that
this is a double top rather than well
like i wait for confirmation because
once you get that confirmation it's a
false breakout and the market snaps back
so really your opportunity is in here
okay
so you know when i say the trade entry
signal is confirmation it's quick quick
confirmation okay because that's what
you want to do you want to take
advantage of the order flow as quickly
as possible
now
the zones
okay
you saw the zones being printed all
right now
i like to use it as sort of
you know a place where i can
hide behind right that i know if it
starts trading against me and it
violates that zone i should be out of
that trade period
okay so
for example now you could make it the
default is set to five